bio lise qui produit des médicaments
contre le cancer entre autres a été
fondée il ya 42 ans par un biologiste
gaspésiens et son épouse la mission de
l'entreprise réduire le coût des
médicaments pour qu'il soit accessible à
tous
en déceler ces gens-la on veut pas vous
aider on est au près
puis parce que ça représente vraiment
le coeur des canadiens en mars dernier
clou mercure a demandé au gouvernement
fédéral le droit de produire des vaccins
anti que vite générique pour les vendre
à une fraction du coût à la bolivie le
canada peut suspendre temporairement le
brevet si le vaccin est où le médicament
est offert un pays à faible revenu neuf
mois plus tard il attend toujours la
réponse ça c'est compliqué même
communiqué sujet la réponse
[Musique]
vous la peau
initiés de la compétition au canada en
tout cas l'épouvantail des des
compagnies pharmaceutiques
qui qui intimide ou qui décourage les
pays à faire la levée des brevets et
apparemment réel l'ancienne présidente
de médecins sans frontières rappelle que
lors de la pandémie de sida en afrique
le canada a été le premier pays sous le
leadership de jean chrétien a adopté un
régime permettant de suspendre
temporairement le brevet ça a été fait
pendant très thérapie au rwanda il pour
le vaccin contre la grippe aviaire
pourquoi ne pas y recourir pour les
vaccins anti qu'ovide je l'expliqué
difficilement mais je pense que c'est
pour ça que je fais des entrevues c'est
que je veux qu'on mette la pression sous
gouverneur canadien nous avons une
compagnie qui est prête un enfer qui est
bio lise et donc on a besoin aujourd'hui
que notre gouvernement
canadien met sur la next 1 qui rajoute
les produits à la coved 19 pour les
médecins qui conseille le ms la panique
provoquée par le variant au micro
devrait convaincre ottawa depuis la
levée des brevets qu'ovide sur tout les
etats-unis la france y sont favorables
la réalité on va palmans s'asseoir sur
notre docteur nos approvisionnements
passent commande de houma god on a
besoin d'une troisième dose et si ça se
trouve peut-être une quatrième dos et un
autre va rien donc on n'est pas prêts à
donner nos vaccins le canada n'a fourni
que 9 des 200 millions de doses promises
aux pays pauvres lever les brevets leur
permettrait de produire des vaccins
abordables et ainsi freiner le
développement de nouveaux variants ici
ce filon gloire radio canada montréal